hi i'm bill gates to invent a better
world we need exciting new ways to solve
the biggest problems so when i got the
opportunity to guess that at the
december issue i jumped at the chance
this issue is full of inspiring and
surprising stories of cutting-edge
innovation to improve people's lives
around the globe like eradicated
diseases easy poverty and educating
children there's a QA with my favorite
author and a conversation I got to have
with President Bill Clinton here's a
look at some dynamic data rich maps that
are helping inform everything from
delivering healthcare and providing
financial services to the poor data has
to be at the center of our efforts to
invent a better world I hope you'll
enjoy
you